[Musique]
je reste soit on va l'aider territoire
sur lequel tout le monde qu'on sait
qu'il y avait des problèmes
la famine la guerre des niveaux record
mais au fur et à mesure ce territoire
est entrain de suffire comprendre
transformation sociale et qui
transforment aujourd'hui chacune ce
problème en unités d'entreprises du
territoire dont je souhaiterais vous
parler ce soir c'est la pression cette
afrique
je l'appelle l'afrique des valeurs le
continent des talents gildas et ses amis
n'ont pas attendu la fin des guerres en
afrique on partir de leurs propres mains
un espace et créativité qui aujourd'hui
des mines est un lieu de pèlerinage pour
li na passe et saint paul aux congolais
n'a pas attendu de résoudre tous les
problèmes de famine en afrique ont
commencé à concevoir des robots à base
de man ray libération
aucun homme à deux ans s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait un manque de
casiers l'ordre il a appris à faire la
formation embarqué qui a des news sur
internet et il a conçu cardiopathie bien
lui de sauver ces camerounais pendant
qu'on réfléchissait aux problèmes de
l'afrique
tu donnes balle au mali diplômé en
médecine a tout lâché pour apprendre à
faire de l'informatique
aujourd'hui il a conçu la plateforme qui
permet de mettre en relation des
médecins et des patients mais il est le
cofondateur d'un espace de créativité où
aujourd'hui il diffuse via des vidéos du
contenu tout la démence dans ton canaria
en a pris chaque jeune africain que je
viens de citer à chronique problème il a
rencontré des difficultés
mais au-delà de cette difficulté il a
roulé une fox source d'inspiration et
ils n'appellent pas le temps aujourd'hui
qui fait de l'afrique territoire la
résilience créative et cette résilience
créative se trouve chaque jeune acteur
tout l'agenda prétend aujourd'hui sont
en train de s'inspirer de nos problèmes
de tous les jours ce que nous appelons
difficulté eux et en somme cela en
opportunité ce que nous appelons
problèmes eux il est écrit une solution
ils sont entrés de bâtir une cette
valeur qui est telle qu'aujourd'hui
on parle rester hors de cette créativité
qui réellement nous permet de voir
l'avenir l'afrique autrement ils sont
tous aujourd'hui un carrefour un
carrefour où ils ont besoin de propulser
leurs activités ils ont besoin de mieux
avancer dans cette démarche de
créativité
mais en face d'eux il y aller quand vous
les grands groupes qui ont du métier à
valoriser des grands groupes qui ont
l'expertisé a diffusé il faut réfléchir
à l'échelle de valeur qui permet à nous
tous aujourd'hui
en hiver c'est avant tout de trouver les
moyens de maintenance en
ces jeunes entrepreneurs qui ont de
l'agilité à partager qui ont aujourd'hui
de la résilience créative à partager et
c'est qu'un groupe qui ont une expertise
et du métier avalisé mais pour faire
cela pour eux ici cette cohésion
il faut mettre en place un mouton près
c'est un modèle qui est basée sur la
bienveillance
un modèle qui est basé sur la
construction
un modèle qui est basée sur la côte
basse mais vous avez tous ces jeunes que
je viens de vous citer se trouvent dans
des pays du coeur
ils ont d'abord un challenge à relever
dans chacun de ces pays
il fut un moment légende transférer
frontières malheureusement nous avons
construit des murs
restez l'heure est venue pour nous
détruit ce mur construit des mots trop
forts que ces jeunes qui crient
aujourd'hui de la valeur dans le pays
puisque entaché cette valeur cette
connaissance avec d'autres jeunes qui se
trouvent dans d'autres capitales
il faut n'établit dépend celle de
croissance partagée d'abord entre les
jeux et après russie a établi un fonds
de valeurs entre tous ces jeux et d'un
gang le plus important dans cette
démarche c'est que dans cette
collaboration entre les jeunes start et
les grands fonds
il est important de mettre en avant
éléments qui est essentielle comment
nous arrivons à valoriser les ressources
créatives et ses jeux qui arrivent pour
l'invitation inspiré par des valeurs on
retrouve sur chacune d'entre d'eux pour
la même relation les vecteurs doute
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont la capacité de
leurs données et l'accès à un marché
régional ou un marché africain
enfin que ces jeunes en cédant un marché
régional se crée déjà des pires
et pendant que ja à développer leur
activité et sept grands groupes qui sont
en pleine structuration qui sont en
plein de consommation territoriale en
pleine consommation digitale plus aussi
accéder à une réelle cristallisation de
l'heure
c'est sûr nous partons de la
colonisation
inspirée par les valeurs des uns et des
autres de chaque acteur et vous avez une
croissance partagée où elle accède à une
accélération de la consommation digitale
et cette jeune start up française à des
marchés africains à démarcher dans la
sous région mais que l'un permet
aujourd'hui d'avancer les premiers pas
mais n'oublions pas que cette démarche
constante doit se bâtir sur du
développement 3d manqué à la tv
l'équité sociale l'efficacité économique
et la qualité environnementale
lorsqu'on collabore avec des jeunes
startups n'oublions pas d'associer ces
trois éléments qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'avancer ensemble sur le
même chemin à travers des vecteurs de
croissance pour aboutir demain parce que
tout le monde recherche aujourd'hui
n'oubliez pas je les dis chaque problème
panafricaine est une idée d'entreprise
mais vous n'arriverez jamais à résoudre
tout seul votre problème
pour résoudre ce problème n'avait besoin
de nous appuyer sur des connaissances
vos connaissances ne suffira pas parce
que la connaissance la m n'a de valeur
que lorsque la partage
on est arrivé à un établissement de
partage en amène un carrefour de
collaboration pour noah d'échanger nos
valeurs on va échanger nos connaissances
compatir cette économie
l'avenir c'est un écosystème que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place pas
une chaîne alimentaire et d'enceintes
consistel vous avez des acteurs clés qui
ont des valeurs des acteurs clés qui
arrive à créer la différence à un moment
donné et je sens
les acteurs qui vont en étroite
collaboration avec d'autres acteurs très
riche elle de valeur pour partie
recettes économiques de demain
et cette économie ne se fait pas sans la
culture
cette économie ne se plaint pas sans
l'autre réalité on ne va jamais réussir
à bâtir l'avenir de l'afrique
et puis l'extérieur on ne va jamais
réussi à mettre en place un dispositif
de développement pour l'avenir de
l'afrique depuis l'extérieur tout
dispositif de développement centre et
sans vote avec des acteurs qui sont des
jeunes innovateurs qui sont des jeunes
startups qui sont des grands comptes
mais aussi dans toute cette image qui
sont en train de crier de la valeur
ajoutée une chose importante qui vaut
pour nous mais aussi pour vous il est
important de ne pas l'oublier
soit nous arrivons aujourd'hui à suivre
en tant qu'écosystème
nous disparaissons individuellement il
ya des initiatives isolées
la mairie de l'afrique se trouve entre
nous mais nous devons arriver à assurer
via nos valeurs une politisation pour
aboutir à une croissance partagée
[Musique]